over over the course of your career you
you've worked with a lot of prosthetics
so
that's a skill set that maybe you could
speak to
for people
watching the show that might want to be
working with prosthetics whether
creating them or as an actor what are
the things that are helpful to you when
you approach a job that does have a lot
of prosthetics as opposed to a job that
has none
oh right well
first of all i get a lot of young actors
getting a hold of me on the social
medias like i want to do what you do and
my answer is oh save yourself
oh you're kidding me
uh yeah
but
uh but no but if it's
if you either
as a performer in a crazy look
you you want to you have to really be
you have to think like an athlete and an
actor because you you do once this look
is on you it might take anywhere from
two to seven hours to get you into that
look every day your energy then has to
be up on camera for the next 12 hours
and then you have to get cleaned up for
the next two hours after that you may
have a turnaround for the next day that
is less than
than ideal you might sleep four hours
maybe and then have to be back at it all
over again the next day so you really do
have to be in the best shape of your
life uh and and you know take care of
yourself with all of the physical stuff
you know hydrate and take your vitamins
and get your sleep and all that stuff
uh if you can but
when it comes to the creature effects
the creators uh
of you know if you if you're one of
those kids who doodled in your notebook
during math class and you're drawing
pictures of demons and fighting angels
uh that's those are the people that
usually end up creating the looks that
have gone on me
and uh
so i would say keep keep that art artist
in you very much
[Music]
all alive the night you're shining
bright i'm your boy's the baby you're my
[Music]